hi I'm love Schwartz bored come on down
to crazy bucks Democratic National
Committee where we are massively
overstocked on presidential candidates
and we've got deals you can't afford to
pass up like a nationwide fifty dollar
minimum wage free college tuition
Medicare for $1,000 cash to every
American every month on the air we've
got so many giveaways we're practically
giving up away howdy folks Steve hacked
our here big Steve's Republican National
Committee and we basically have two
options for you so if you like old white
guys Jeff I tougher immigration
restrictions will get them for you
crippling trade war will do that too big
bailout to cover all the losses from the
crippling trade war you can have that or
you can have complete opposite of all of
those things if basically it could go
either way no credit bad credit visas
violent felony conviction you can still
have it all subsidies for green energy
for we universal pre-k paid parental
leave on 12 new Supreme Court justices
taxes will cut a car regulations will
slash a washer national debt
but if somebody kneels in a football
game totally gonna stick it to that guy
on Twitter so if you value freedom and
equality under the law for all Americans
regardless of race religion gender or
sexual orientation I promise you it's
pot we if we might bomb Mexico boom or
not it could go the other way too
so free US Treasury bonds to every
newborn child in America
something about banking at a post office
we even get a break up Facebook and
credit good interest rates see one of
them used to be libertarians but he who
was a Republican before that and the
other actually start his Democrat and
then became a Republican and then joined
the Reform Party and and then back to a
Democrat and then Republican again and
then independents but now I guess he's a
Republican so you can trust us ten
billion dollars in slavery reparation
trillion dollars for climate change
stuff it's all weird we're gonna
overturn citizens united because we have
to get money out of politics so go down
the route 51 just pass the Starbucks
don't even look at a Starbucks just pass
the Starbucks then take a hard left just
off highway 88 between the chick-fil-a
in the exa big Steve's Republican
National Committee our inventory may be
low but our convictions are even lower
[Music]
committee we've got the greatest deals
in history we are doomed to repeat
you